avant on va parler de théâtre avec cette
création qui est proposée au théâtre
humanum d'Avignon du 7 au 29 juillet tu
as l'occasion du Festival OFF qui se
tient dans la ville à l'ouest une pièce
écrite par Jean anouil en 1952 et qui
est adapté cette fois-ci par une
compagnie yvelinoise qui s'appelle agar
il y a de représentants de membres de
cette compagnie qui sont avec nous en
plateau Cécile Palou qui est à metteuse
en scène et Bérénice Lemaistre qui est
comédienne de cette compagnie on disait
tout à l'heure première création pour la
compagnie agar dans quel état d'esprit
êtes-vous à quelques jours du début de
ce festival off d'Avignon qui va marquer
un peu le début de l'aventure officielle
moi je suis content que là j'ai plus ni
de stress ni d'appréhension juste
contente qu'on y aille et qu'on présente
notre travail ça fait quand même des
mois qu'on travaille et bah je suis
fière d'eux donc j'attends de enfin
voilà quoi
c'est un grand challenge et je pense
qu'on y va tous avec une immense envie
de défendre ce projet c'est ouais c'est
aussi l'aboutissement de plusieurs mois
de travail etc donc c'est chouette
vraiment de pouvoir se confronter là au
public parce que le festival Avignon
c'est
un immense rendez-vous du théâtre donc
s'il y a une grande émulation dans la
ville c'est exceptionnel aussi pour nous
de pouvoir y participer donc ce sera
pour présenter à l'ouest alors juste
pour resituer une somme au 15e siècle le
plus précisément 1431 à Rouen et on va
croiser la route d'un personnage
iconique de l'histoire de France c'est
bien sûr Jeanne d'Arc
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter un
petit peu l'intrigue de cette pièce
alors du coup donc ouais ça on est en
1431 on est à Rouen et c'est son procès
donc le maître des des bas c'est cochons
qui en évêque et dans sa pièce Jean
anouil il fait plusieurs dimensions donc
il y a aussi les flashback et donc on
voit ce qu'il y a amené Jeanne d'Arc et
son épopée et il y a aussi cette notion
de mise en abyme parce que les
personnages sont tous au courant qui
jouent et voilà c'est une pièce qui est
assez complexe assez complexe et qui est
proche de la réalité ou
il a pris des libertés dans l'écriture
c'est beaucoup amusé il y a beaucoup
beaucoup d'humour dans cette pièce c'est
une tragique comédie parce que d'un côté
bon on connaît tous l'histoire de Jeanne
d'Arc bon a priori il y a un bûcher à un
moment donné mais il y a beaucoup
beaucoup d'humour et en fait toutes ces
scènes où elle est avec ses parents donc
dans les flashbacks où elle rencontre
Baudricourt le capitaine de vos couleurs
pour le convaincre avec le futur roi
Charles VII aussi il y a beaucoup
d'humour c'est à dire comme il le dit
lui-même dans la réalité ça c'est pas
exactement passé comme ça donc il y a
cette dimension dans l'écriture d'un
nouilles c'est beaucoup de phrases aussi
très percutantes très efficace il y a
une langue chatouille mais
voilà c'est c'est une très belle pièce
en tout cas très bien et très bien
écrite et pourquoi le personnage de
Jeanne d'Arc pourquoi ça vous a inspiré
pourquoi le prendre cet exemple pour
commencer je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup Jeanne d'Arc
C Jeanne d'Arc mais en lisant ça je me
suis mis
à
de moi et de et de nous tous il y avait
plein de personnages qui me parlaient
énormément et elle est trop belle dans
sa manière de faire les choses et elle
va jusqu'au bout bon c'est tragique sa
fin mais la manière dont et puis il y a
des phrases qui sont authentiques que
Jeanne d'Arc a vraiment dit et qui
résonne encore tellement aujourd'hui
tout ça ça faisait que c'était assez une
évidence quand j'ai lu la pièce donc
elle a une part de modernité finalement
on ne voulait pas qu'elle s'habille
comme un homme et la tenue des femmes ça
reste un sujet actuel et je trouvais ça
je trouve que c'est un impact de
rappeler que ça fait en fait des
centaines d'années que ces problématique
quoi et donc la pièce je le disais a été
écrite en 1952 comment vous avez
justement pensé la mise en scène est-ce
que vous avez peut-être c'est de la
moderniser davantage on a bien compris
que le personnage était moderne déjà
mais comment vous y êtes pris du coup
sur la mise en scène ben nos costumes
ils sont assez minimalistes nos décors
sont assez minimalistes donc il y a
beaucoup de place à l'imaginaire et la
langue même si c'est la langue d'anouil
donc il est langue assez théâtrale il y
a quand même des choses qui sont très
très modernes et puis de toute façon
dans leur manière de jouer il y a un
truc qui est complètement
enfin d'aujourd'hui quoi ça s'adresse à
nous et puis on est jeune et puis du
coup il y a ce truc là où c'est c'est
pour aujourd'hui quoi il y a 8 comédiens
sur scène alors qui jouent différents
rôles vous bérenise de jouer le
promoteur Boudou c'est la reine Yolande
c'est pas difficile à organiser tout ça
pas vraiment non en fait
bon cécile a rendu les choses de toute
façon assez lisible il y a des codes
avec les costumes c'est à dire il y a
des symboles donc on peut aussi
reconnaître les personnages selon les
symboles et en fait c'est surtout hyper
intéressant et amusant en tant que
comédien parce que ça ouvre un champ des
possibles c'est à dire le Boudou c'est
un garde je vais l'interpréter un peu
d'une certaine manière qui différente la
reine violente donc ça permet aussi de
d'explorer différentes choses de
proposer aussi une palette et de
comédiens donc c'est c'est plutôt
enrichissant et amusant en tant comédien
Olivier donc très peu de costumes
puisque la pièce à la base il faut le
dire il y a beaucoup de costumes dans
cette pièce vous avez préféré la jouer
un peu plus minimaliste
symboliques il y a des trucs comme ça on
comprend à quel endroit c'est à quel
endroit c'est mais
il y a un phénomène dans le théâtre
c'est que moi il y en a plus ça fait
travailler l'imaginaire et c'est ça que
je trouve trop cool comme moi je vais au
théâtre qu'il y ait pas grand chose et
que du coup je vois mille choses et je
trouve que c'est ça qui reste le plus et
donc c'est un peu sur ça qu'on a joué
enfin que de l'idée de base jusqu'à
jusqu'à aujourd'hui jusqu'à
c'est la présentation de cette pièce à
Avignon il y a eu combien de temps de
travail
plusieurs mois plusieurs mois plusieurs
mois de répétition de résidence on en a
notamment fait nos Vésinet
dans les Yvelines c'est Made in Yvelines
avec les Yvelines et ça fait oui depuis
fin novembre qu'on a commencé à répéter
toutes les semaines donc là c'est la
première création c'est quoi les
objectifs c'est que ce soit la première
d'une longue lignée c'est début d'une
aventure on espère on espère du coup on
a créé cette compagnie on espère que ce
sera plein de projets tous ensemble et
que l'alouette aussi vivra le plus
longtemps possible vous allez jouer tous
les jours sauf le mardi si j'ai pas de
bêtises c'est bien ça et en plus ce sera
le matin est-ce que c'est un paramètre à
prendre en compte ou
pas
tenir la durée d'un festival sachant
qu'au-delà des représentations c'est
aussi tout ce qu'il faut faire pour
amener les gens c'est à dire qu'il y
aura des joueurs de tractage c'est
plusieurs centaines de spectacles à ce
moment-là Avignon donc il faut aussi
réussir à faire sa place et attirer du
public parce que son ça le théâtre n'est
rien on a besoin de gens pour jouer
d'avoir des gens en face de nous c'est
une question de partage encore une fois
ça vous donne envie Véronique
sera jouée sur la scène du théâtre en
Avignon lors du Festival of Strad du 7
au 29 juillet et on disait tous les
jours sauf les mardis à 10h40 toutes les
informations à retrouver sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci à vous deux d'être venu en parler
en plateau et souhaite bonne chance pour
ce festival off d'Avignon qui va
s'ouvrir à très prochainement le 7
juillet en Avignon